good afternoon i'm lieutenant ray
spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm here this afternoon to brief you on
the homicide investigation that we have
been conducting for the last
10 days that occurred a week ago friday
in
mountain springs over
the last 10 days we have put in a
tremendous amount of resources
and effort in an attempt to identify the
victim of the homicide that occurred
i specifically want to thank a few
agencies
that has made this press conference
possible this afternoon
first off i'd like to thank the clark
county coroner's office they have been a
tremendous partner
and they have also worked tyrus
tirelessly
the last week and a half on this case
in addition i want to thank the san jose
police department
for the work that they have done to
assist us in identifying
the victim and lastly the work from the
forensics lab
who worked and came in over the weekend
to make an identification
possible so i will walk you through some
of the details that occurred
starting friday night so again all last
week we had detectives working
through hundreds of leads in an effort
to identify
the victim friday evening at around 8pm
i received a phone call
from a sergeant with the san jose police
department
who stated that they believed they had a
potential
victim of a missing person who they
believed
may have been our victim that point they
sent
photographs to me after looking at those
photographs
we believed that there was a very good
possibility
that the missing person case that they
were working in san jose was related to
our homicide investigation
the following morning saturday morning
we
did a lot of work up in investigative
techniques in an effort to positively
identify
and link the two cases that morning i
sent a detective to san jose california
they flew there they retrieved a
clothing and a pillow that belonged to
the missing
seven-year-old child in san jose that
detective flew back to las vegas a
couple hours later
and yesterday morning a scientist came
into the forensic lab and began working
on processing dna evidence
to confirm that the victim was in fact
the seven-year-old child
late last night we positively identified
the victim as seven-year-old liam
houstead l-i-a-m houstead h-u-s-t-e-d
he is a seven-year-old child who lives
in san jose california
what we have learned is that he has last
seen
in the san jose area on may 24th
so what occurred was a family friend
of the mother who is 35 year old
samantha
marino rodriguez the family
friend stated that she had not seen
samantha or liam
in over two weeks she also knew that
there was a missing or
that the two of them were missing she
saw
news coverage from our case here in las
vegas and saw the composite sketch
that was pushed out to the media after
seeing that
she believed that the sketch resembled
liam
she then went to the san jose police
department on friday
prompting the chain of events that i
outlined
so what we have learned from the two of
them
samantha and liam left san jose
california
driving a 19 i'm sorry a 2007
dark blue dodge caliber
they left san jose on the 24th of may
we can place them in the area of laguna
beach
on the afternoon of the 26th of may
later that afternoon we know the vehicle
was in the area of victorville
california
on late in the afternoon on the 26th of
may
liam was discovered early in the morning
on the 28th
of may shortly thereafter on the 29th of
may
we know that the vehicle was traveling
on i-70
near grand junction colorado
the last contact that anyone has seen
of samantha is at a denver area hotel
room
on the 31st of may when she checked in
by herself to a hotel room in the denver
area
at this point there is about an hour ago
we obtained an arrest warrant
nationwide extradition for open murder
for samantha marino rodriguez
i urge anyone we still need assistance
anyone who may have recognized her
and liam in the las vegas valley on the
27th or 28th of
may driving again the dark blue
dodge caliber we understand that the
vehicle
was packed full of belongings and when i
say packed i believe that the back seat
and cargo compartment of the car had no
room for anyone to sit
and it was packed completely we are
asking anyone who works at a hotel or a
motel in the las vegas valley to please
check their hotel register
for the days of the 27th and 28th
to see if samantha checked into a hotel
here in the las vegas valley
you can also if that is the if you have
that information you can reach out to
crime stoppers
or you can call the homicide tip line at
702-828-3521
so again there's a lot of moving parts
to this investigation it is still
extremely active and ongoing
the fbi local office here in their
national
national field offices are assisting us
at this point
in attempting to apprehend samantha
with that i will take a couple questions
what do you know about
rodriguez what have you learned again
she's a
35 year old woman who lives in the san
jose area
and again that she is the mother of
seven-year-old liam
we know again she left on the 24th and
that's
what prompted this investigation in the
back was there ever a sign of
did they talk about a relationship or a
history of abuse or anything
there's nothing at this point that would
indicate there's any prior
abuse that we're aware of again it's
still a lot of moving parts and still
very active
but nothing that has been brought to our
attention at this point do you know
anything about why they left san jose
we don't know the specifics we're still
trying to find out we're still
interviewing family and friends
trying to piece all that together any
possible motive
we don't know a possible motive that's
why we're still
reaching out we're still asking for the
public's assistance or anybody who knows
her
to reach out to us or anyone who's had
any communication specifically
to reach out to the police department i
just have a follow-up did you have to
break the news to this child's parents
that
this was his body and can you kind of
talk about that
the clark county coroner specifically
made the death notification
i spoke with the father about 60 minutes
ago before i came out here
because i didn't want him to see this
press conference without me explaining
what was about to transpire
i will tell you it's a heartbreaking
conversation to have
this has been an emotional last 10 days
for myself
all the investigators that have been
working on it and we're just glad we're
able to get some closure for liam
and then hold the person responsible for
this crime accountable so that's
what our focus is right now yes any
connection to las vegas with the two
that you know we don't know i mean we do
know that samantha has visited las vegas
in the past there's been photographs
that we have recovered that does show
that she's been here previously
but as far as why she was in the las
vegas valley that day we don't know
yes
at this point we believe from the
information that we have obtained at
this point we believe she is traveling
alone
and she was last seen alone in the
denver area on the 31st
do you know anything about the
relationship between her and the boy's
father
i'm not going to get into the specifics
of that on
that portion of it i don't know enough
about the family dynamics so liam wasn't
officially declared a missing person
until friday right
were there any indications that they
were trying to get a hold of them on the
days prior
so the father had made a report on the
first
but the father did not feel that his son
was in harm's way when the mother left
with the child
he did contact the police because he had
not heard from her or
his son again not trying to get the
mother into trouble he didn't want to
file any type of charges or anything but
he did contact
the police on the first and just to be
clear he is
not a suspect and there is no
involvement whatsoever
that we suspect on his behalf
in the back thank you i appreciate it